this is another fella who uh put in
there he once insists on the
ether and he says light is just a
vibration in the ether medium
the medium is dipolar electrons and
positron pairs
particles that repel each other matters
a crystalline structure
of photons ether medium particles
squeeze into a crystalline structure
quantum ether is a mathematical uh with
predictive power it cannot have material
existence
no kidding so if ether is not material i
don't know what kind of physics we're
doing here
gravity is the movement of these medium
particles towards the low pressure area
created by
constriction in the medium flowing
around and created by matter
well i don't know what all that means
i'm just going to address the ether
because that's what we're concerned he
says the vibration of the ether medium
here's what this guy is proposing he's
saying look uh
that's light light is the vibration of
the ether medium so he
sees a some kind of vibration that
wiggly worm that you see there
and what is that wiggly worm well it's
just the vibration all those particles
that's what it is they're moving up and
down they're causing this
uh wiggling and he says that's what
light is that's what a lot of people out
there think
light is the vibration of the ether okay
so that's that's the starting point but
let's we have to go one step back
because these people are already moving
ahead into theory
and we're not interested in the theory
we want to get to the bottom of the
ether we want to know what this ether
stuff is
so that's where we have to start we
haven't finished with the ether and you
can't even start your theory until we
cover
every base on the ether okay so let's go
with the ether here
this is the ether this person is
proposing he's saying it's made of
positrons and electrons etc
what are positrons what are electrons
what
is the black stuff that contours each
one of these little balls
assuming these are little balls that's
what i'm assuming i'm assuming that
when the person says electron he's
thinking about a tiny little bead
we're going to think of it as a round
one because that's that's convenient
only because of that so what contours
that ball what contours the red and
white balls here you know you can have
an infinite ether here's here's the same
thing but infinite
irrespective we need to know what that
black stuff is we want to know what
what is that black stuff that gives
shape to each one of those particles
let's zoom in with our microscope and
find out
what this looks like and here you see
what it looks like okay we have the
electron particle and the positron
particle okay
one is red the other one is white one
carries a negative sign above its head
and the other one a positive sign
now how do these two things attract each
other i mean
physically does the plus sign get
somehow tangled with the
negative sign is that how the attraction
occurs between these two particles
in other words we've got several issues
here we have first the issue what's the
black stuff
i need to know what's contouring each
one of those two particles
the second issue is okay even if we can
see that how does one particle
attract the other are we just going to
use the magic one and say well they do
and positive attracts negative well what
does positive mean in physical terms
what does negative mean in physical
terms
unless you can put this in physical
terms that plus and minus are
absolutely nothing they're just
descriptions you're saying well whenever
we
have you know particle attract another
we'll call this one the positive one and
that one the negative one
and by definition the positive one is
the positron and the other one is the
electron we're done
that's only a description that's
labeling you still haven't told me the
mechanism
and uh so what i do is um
just put out a set of questions that
anyone who proposes the
famous ether has to answer okay these
are the questions okay
does the ether fill space or is the
ether equal to space
in other words are space and ether
synonyms the same
equal etc what encapsulates
each particle that constitutes the ether
in other words what's that black stuff
if space contours each particle of ether
what is space define or draw a space i
need to
for you to give me a definition of the
word space or if you think it's an
object i want you to draw it and in
which case
you know is space infinite or finite
well
if it's finite meaning it's an object
you got to tell me what encapsulates
space
and if it's infinite well what do you
mean by infinite what do you mean that
space is infinite what does that mean
is space a physical object that is
infinite
and then the last one is the ether
within an uh
it is the ether within an infinite space
infinite or finite because space you can
say maybe
you manage to defend the fact that it's
infinite
okay and then the question is the ether
within that space
uh finite or infinite i mean
do we have this situation see there's
space
we're going to assume it's infinite and
the ether which is that
the red and white balls the body there
is that finite it stops somewhere and
then space continues to infinity
whatever infinity is
and if space is not infinite what
contour space what encapsulates space
so those are the questions that the
proponent of ether has to
answer before they rant about their
theories we don't want to hear your
theories
okay we don't want to hear your theories
because they're bunk unless you can get
through
the the qualitative
assumptions that you need to start your
theory
you need to finish with the ether you
have been finished with your theory
spend two years on the ether one second
on your theory okay
it's the other way around you want to
talk about your theory how the ether
vibrates and yeah and we proved it in
the
in the lab we don't want to hear any of
that we want to know what the ether
is before you start we're going to
bombard you with questions on
what the ether is what contours each
particle is space
infinite those are the questions we want
answered